[MUSIC].
Change lives.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> Change lives.
>> Change organizations,.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> Change organizations.
>> Change the world.
[MUSIC].
>> When we say change lives,
change organizations.
And change the world, we really mean it.
Stanford GSB equips students to do that.
>> You first have to start by changing
yourself.
>> Students are naturally encouraged to
innovate.
>> We tend to attract students,
we tend to attract faculty who are not
fearful of making mistakes.
The fear is much more on missing out on an
opportunity.
There's extreme committment to, I came to
change the world.
I'm going to change the world.
What does that mean?
My comfort zone ceases to exist.
>> GSP encourages you to risk-
>> Broadens your perspectives on how to
influence how to lead.
>> I learned to be a critical, analytical
thinker.
Understand the global contacts of
management.
>> The research in governance that were
doing.
It shows up in SCC, discussions.
Is used by companies in the deciding how
they design their compensation programs,
how they want to structure their board of
directors.
This is not a school where we'd simply
training leaders for the domestic economy.
>> With the GSB, I can easily measure the
whole world while studying at this place.
>> In film directors, bankers, and private
equity consultants.
>> Renowned leaders from around the world,
a Nobel prize winner.
>> It's really a transformation, you know,
it's.
Experience.
>> Change lives.
>> Change organizations.
>> Change the world.
>> I just expected going to a top business
school,
that everyone was gonna be super
competitive with each other.
It's not like that at all.
>> Going through the leadership curriculum
has really helped build my confidence, and
my ability to manage a high-performing
team.
>> I graduated from Stanford Business
School in 2000.
[MUSIC].
Authentic leadership and
especially the way it's used at Standford.
Being self-reflective, self-aware and
mission driven.
That ability to, to see myself and be true
to myself.
Truly, like, the couple years I spent at
Stanford Business School
have helped shape what I do as a global
leader.
>> Change lives.
>> Change your organizations.
>> Change the world.
[MUSIC].
>> If there is no Stanford Graduate School
of Business [UNKNOWN] it was in
the entrepreneurship class with [UNKNOWN]
that I
wrote the paper that really became the
blueprint for Nike.
>> The [UNKNOWN] Management Center
represents a giant leap forward for
the Graduate School of Business.
Through curriculum reform,
we now provide a very unique management
education experience.
It is experiential, it's transformative,
it's individualized, personalized, and
now we have the physical facility to put
that in.
>> The Knight Center really demonstrates
teaching and
living responsibly with concerns for
sustainable design.
[MUSIC]
This place is so much more than a physical
facility.
.
So
here I'm standing on the edge of a town
square, next to the [UNKNOWN] cafe.
Then a bunch of community court.
You can walk by at ten o' clock at night,
and you will see students inventing the
future in front of your eyes.
>> Everything on campus is within walking
distance of everything else.
The university as a whole is a giant
resource to the students.
>> The physical space grounds us, enabling
the ideas that are generated here to
go way beyond the walls of Hasso Plattner
Center.
[MUSIC].
I'm really interested in entrepreneurship
and innovation.
>> Energy and clean tax space.
>> Be working in tourism in three.
>> Private equity.
>> Combining business and medicine.
>> Stab for GSB, lose them with
individuals ability to affect change.
>> Make a difference in the lives of you
know, 100s, 1,000,000s of people.
>> The corner stone.
Of our new campus reads dedicated to the
things that haven't happened yet, and
the people who will dream them up.
And I think that, in a nutshell,captures
the essence of the GSB.
>> Pursue your dream.
>> Dream on a world scale.
>> I can do whatever I put my mind to.
>> Change lives.
>> Change organizations.
>> And change the world.
[MUSIC].